I was abducted
I don't know how and I don't know why
but I was abducted in some kind of
portal opened up and I just
they call it this light
I thought I was dreaming at first so
many gods from all over human history
covering almost every mythology you can
think of it was beautiful
a dream come true at first I was
enraptured
it was beautiful it was like a movie
unfold them before my eyes and music
but I knew there was a dark secret
behind all of it
true the ringleaders I think they're
sisters Athena and Nyx they were so much
stronger together stronger than the sum
of their parts but I guess even dreams
can turn into nightmares they took
something from me they scanned me
copied me even now I feel like a part of
myself is still locked in the world of
dislike I kept saying over and over
again something about the link in the
description below that I can download
for free what does that even mean
download for free they kept offering me
things for free NYX a five-star hero
said that she would join my team for
free if I just click the link in the
description below
couldn't believe it I refuse to believe
it
maybe I do
[Music]
maybe I want to believe it but I can't
believe it I shouldn't believe it no one
should believe the things that I believe
but I don't believe the things that I
believe but if I don't believe the
things that I believe in how can you
believe what I'm believing so I say not
to believe it and not believe what you
believe in because if you believe in it
you might just find the link in the
description below
[Music]
who's in space
glorious beautiful space
all right Evan
no it can't be true I know who I am do
you know who I am can you tell that I am
who I am because the me that I know that
I am is the me that I know that I will
be when I meet and do you know the me
that I am
I don't even know it's real anymore
[Music]
honestly
I don't know if I even care if I'm
oh there's a link somewhere somewhere
there is a link what is the link what
does the link mean what do you know
about the link
anybody knows what the link actually is
but I do know that it's free and if you
can get to it you too can
and then maybe I can be free but I am
free because I escape from it they
abducted me they may have copied me but
I know what I am I might be I might be
part of myself but the half of me that
is still here is still better than the
whole of me that didn't know half of the
things that I know now the half of me
that you see before you
is the other half that you don't know
half as well as you should visit an RPG
is it a mobile game is it a movie is it
a beautiful story that can't help but
explore these are answers questions that
I don't know I don't know if it's an
answer question but I don't know if it's
a question that I should answer who's
[Music]
or at least I think
I escaped I did I escaped for free the
game is free the link in the description
is free the five-star hero you'll get is
free
but am I fat hi sorry about that my
camera must have glitched out it's me
Markiplier
anyway you can check out
hold on there we go I'm here to tell you
all about dislike the game that you can
download through the link in the
description below for free and if you do
you'll get the free five-star hero
Knicks with your downloads so you can
get started on your journey today it's
got great graphics awesome music and
full CD movies for its Heroes be sure to
combine Your Heroes especially Athena
and Nyx because they're stronger
together than they are separate
also I'm in the game
and I'm here
don't ask too many questions about how
that's possible I simply am in the game
and here at the same time
all me every single one of the me that
you see is the me that I am so don't
worry about anything being complicated
about that everything is fine go ahead
and click the link in the description
below and start building your team of
gods from all sorts of mythologies today
connect to the story of Athena and Nix
and find out where their story evolves
will you choose the hypocritical and
weak kindness or the true and brave evil
play today see how athene's story
expands Link in the description
I'm me